- [Laita] All right Gloria.
Gloria, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I was born in Lancaster.
At AV Hospital.
- [Laita] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents growing up?
- My birth mom abandoned me and
she was on drugs.
And when I was an infant.
She let anything happen to me like,
they did you know, finger me and all that,
when I was a baby.
She was just sitting there to just,
you know watching to get the drugs
cause she was, you know, desperate for it.
Or whatever.
And then I don't know
how long it was going.
So she you know keep,
you know always doing it to
get the drugs or whatever.
- [Laita] So basically selling you out?
- Yeah basically, you know,
letting things happen to me.
And I guess Mike found out.
So they took me from hers.
So I was in a lot of different
foster homes getting beat.
Shot up with heroin, left for dead.
And like you know,
traumatized or whatever.
Then my birth mom found
out that she was pregnant
with twins, with my sister
and her twin brother.
And she was still doing drugs.
And she was in a garage
and she gave birth to them.
Tried to toss them like they was trash.
And they, she put them in a trash bag,
tied them up and tried to you know,
toss them in the trashcan and stuff.
The neighbors saw, so they called 9-1-1.
She got arrested, so she's doing life.
And I don't know her first
name and none of that.
I don't know nothing about her,
I don't know nothing about my father.
But my baby brother didn't
survive but she did.
Like she's 14 now, you know,
she don't know she's, you
know confused and stuff.
And you know.
And I didn't even know until
my adoptive mom told me.
We didn't even know she
was our adoptive mom
until she told us when I was like,
probably like seven years old.
And she was like, you
know, a little younger.
And we thought she was our birth mom.
We felt bad, sad, depressed,
like we was wondering
like, who's our birth mom?
What's she look like?
Where we came from?
She told us and this and that.
She told her that she gave,
she was born in a garage
and I was born in AV,
AV Hospital.
And stuff.
And then we was like, you know, torn,
but at the same time you know,
we gotta, you know,
suck it up or whatever.
And,
I was 14 whatever.
My god-dad passed away
before my 15th birthday.
He was (mumbles) or whatever,
I didn't know what to do.
I started thinking negative about myself.
He was the only person I
could open up to or go to,
and trust.
Him, couple days later I find
out my auntie passed away.
Couple days later my cousin passed away,
like three deaths at once.
In different months and years and stuff.
And I thought I can't do it no more.
So I started hanging out
with the wrong crowd.
Got us to weed, weed and
alcohol, started drinking.
Thought I was cool, so ran away from home,
got on the street.
Going back and forth.
And I'd do whatever to,
you know, to fit in,
cause I didn't know how to fit in.
I was looking for love
in the wrong places.
And trusting guys, got set up, got raped.
Gun pulled to my head twice.
Forced me to, you know, do
stuff with guys to make money
or sell drugs.
If I don't do it, they gonna end my life
or end my family life.
And I didn't wanted that.
So I started doing whatever I gotta do
to order to keep my family
alive and keep myself alive.
And so I started selling drugs.
Started stealing from the stores,
selling baby clothes, shoes and all that.
And then got caught up with my ex
for a burglary that I didn't do,
so I went up, got locked up at 16.
Been in there for like a month.
Got out on, supposed
to be on house arrest,
but I didn't get out on house arrest.
I went home.
Me and my mom get in an argument,
she was accusing me of
stealing her cigarettes,
accusing me of stealing
her stuff out her room
or out the cabinet without asking.
And every time my little sister do stuff,
she'd blame it on me.
And I started feeling some type of way.
Started like, oh nobody care
about me, nobody love me.
So I started splitting my wrists, started,
try to overdose three times.
Didn't work and I was like,
"Fuck it it's whatever."
And you know, just you
know, running in the street.
Fighting left and right.
And I didn't like that and I regret it.
And stuff.
But it's like, it's really hard.
Now I started writing poetry,
you know, telling my story.
It's kinda hard to tell my story
cause sometimes when I talk about it
I start crying a little bit, kinda hurt.
But sometimes I gotta
suck it up, you know,
to let other people know
that they not alone.
Cause at first I thought I was by myself,
I thought I was alone.
I didn't know anybody
had anything in common.
You know, I thought nobody believed me,
nobody trusted me, nobody
cared, none of that.
But I do have somebody who do care.
It's like I've been pushing everybody
that care about me and love me,
and brung the negative from around me
and pushed away the positive.
And I realized it in
October 11th, 2018.
I gotta introduced to crys.
I was depressed, I was
tryna end my life that day,
but someone was like,
"Don't do that, just
smoke this, have fun."
So he was controlling
me, every time, you now,
he had me smoke it, he
started ripping my clothes up,
started, you know, doing
stuff that I didn't approve,
he'd get on top of me, do whatever.
He controlled me, I can't
leave out his sight.
He'd get mad when I'm
talking to another guy.
And I told him I'm not his female
and he's claiming me.
And I finally tried to
got away October 30th.
And that day I tried to overdose,
that day I almost died if I
never got rushed to the hospital
I coulda died that day.
And my adoptive mom found
out, she came out here,
came all the way to
Lancaster from Victorville.
To get me, talk to me, telling me like,
"Why you doing these drugs,
"I don't understand why
you can't talk to me.
"You could come and tell me anything."
But that's the thing, I'm
kinda scare to tell her stuff
cause I know how she gets.
She reacts over little things.
She get mad, she cuts me
out, she bring up the past.
She's always saying,
"Oh you ain't gonna be shit.
"You gone be like your birth mom,
"doin' drugs on these
streets or being in prison.
"If you keep it up, you need to you know,
"fix your life around, you have siblings,
"your sister is looking up to you."
And then when she said that
I started breaking down,
like fuck, like I don't want my sister
go through the things that I been through.
I don't want no kids go through the things
that I been through.
Cause it's not right at all.
Cause the things that I been
through and she been through,
it's not our fault, it's our
parents' fault, you know?
But at the same time it's
like, I forgive them.
Not for what they did, but to
order to forgive, to move on,
not try to hold it against them,
because we don't know
what made them to do that.
Cause they probably was
going through something
they didn't know how to cope it.
The only way they cope it is doing drugs.
And drugs don't get you nowhere, at all.
So that's how I feel
and hurt and all that.
- [Laita] So today you're living where?
- [Gloria] In a tent.
- [Laita] On Skid Row.
- [Gloria] In the Skid Row, yeah.
- [Laita] And, using crystal meth.
- [Gloria] Doing crystal meth.
- [Laita] What do you do for money now?
- [Gloria] I panhandle.
Or only if I can't do what I need to do.
I probably sell my body only
like once or twice, that's it.
- [Laita] Oh.
- [Gloria] That I, that I know of.
And I'm scared to do that again.
- [Laita] Yeah you should be.
- [Gloria] Yeah.
- [Laita] And do you have any family,
or friends that you can go to, or?
- [Gloria] I mean, my family,
they kinda talk to me,
but they barely talk to me now
because of my adoptive mom
cause wherever she find out
what I do and the drugs
that I do, they don't,
my family don't mess with me cause
the drugs I'm doing,
and they want the best for me,
but they don't want me around them.
When I'm on drugs or, and stuff.
They say if I could get myself
clean, get the help I need,
to order to just come
back around the family.
(cars driving by)
- [Laita] What do you think about your,
what was the biggest
factor in your childhood
that kinda set you on
this path, you think?
- [Gloria] That made me -
- [Laita] The molestation, or the -
- [Gloria] The molestation.
- [Laita] Or your mom not
being around, or dad, or.
- The molestation, cause I feel
like a part of me is missing
but I can't actually know
what about that but myself
and my birth mom.
Because ever since that day, what she did
to me and my siblings.
I been lost, unsure, don't
know what's going on,
I want answers, but I don't
know how imma get it though.
From her.
Don't know if she's still alive or not.
I'm scared to look for her,
scared to know who she really is.
And I'm scared to be running up like her.
I know I can do better.
And smarter than that.
And do anything I could put my mind to.
- [Laita] You're 21?
- I'm only 18.
- [Laita] Oh you're 18.
And you have a boyfriend?
- Yes, I do.
- [Laita] And he's good to you, or?
How does that relationship?
- Our relationship is really good.
We get in an argument here
and there, you know, a little
ups and downs but you know,
he always treat me right.
He makes sure I'm safe, you know.
And nothing harm me or none of that.
He's the only guy that I ever
trust that I could talk to.
Me and him been best
friends for two years.
And I don't know where we
finally found out that we had
liked each other and then we got together.
- [Laita] Where would you like to be
in a couple years?
I mean you got any
plans for doing anything
to get off the streets?
- That I haven't think of yet,
but I was thinking to put my
poetry out there like that.
Or put it on Facebook, making
something to put it out
on Facebook to let
everybody see on Facebook.
And let them know that never give up
because if you give up,
you don't know if you could
achieve your goals.
Cause how you gone achieve your goals
if you'll give up?
Keep trying.
Even though if you fail, get back up.
And keep going.
Whatever is in the past,
whatever you been through
and it's not your fault.
Just keep going.
And that's all I gotta say.
- [Laita] You've been
living on the streets
for how long now, since you?
- Since I was 14.
- [Laita] 14.
- Til, til I'm 18 now.
- [Laita] Yeah, how do you
think that those four years
have affected you?
- It affected me a lot, you know.
But I'm staying strong as best as I can
to order to let people
know that I'm strong,
I could conquer my goals and not affect,
not think about the pain.
Even though I could feel the pain,
even though I could think
about it here and there,
trying not to think
about it best as I can.
- [Laita] All right Gloria.
Thank you for coming
in and talking with me.